what is up everybody welcome back to the
cosmic wonder i'm your host warren
thompson and it's finally happened we
finally have our very first interview
with all three
spider-man toby mcguire andrew garfield
and of course tom holland finally we've
been waiting for this since the release
of the movie this was released on the
official spider-man youtube page
i haven't seen it yet
i wanted to do a reaction that's like
genuine and live and
i'm really excited i want to know all
about what it was like when they filmed
with each other
before the movie started after the movie
started all of their little secrets they
had to keep i want to know everything so
let's not waste any time because it's
like 30 minutes long so let's just jump
right into this i'm excited
hi there i'm pete hammond and happy to
moderate this session i am the only one
you were looking at on the screen who
has never played spiderman and uh this
is exciting i i think it's almost
historic we have the three in the last
20 years of this franchise uh toby
maguire who of course started it all
with the first three spider-man hi toby
the pioneer in this and then of course
andrew garfield who carried it on in the
next year
and now tom holland who's completed his
first trilogy we'll find out if there's
more
with bob holland right here
uh welcome and wow uh i have to say
right off the bat did any of you have
any idea
that this movie would have the impact
that it's had around the globe
beyond all expectations i think even for
spider-man i mean tom did you uh you
know having just done
the third one now
i mean i think i i always knew that this
film would be
would be loved around the world i didn't
think it would be quite
as massive as it has been you know one
of my favorite things to do at the
minute is to go online and watch fans
reactions to you guys coming in that one
scene in particular
i i just i don't think i could ever have
imagined it as being so well received by
by everyone um
so no i mean i guess i had an idea that
people would love this movie but in no
way shape or form could i have thought
it was going to be as big as it has been
uh and it's been you know only the last
couple weeks if i sort of really come
back to reality and come home and
started to face real world problems
and it feels like we've been on some
sort of really weird dream
it feels really strange
it does in a way but it was it's so
exciting i had the advantage of being at
the very first press screening so to me
it was brand new which is the way
anybody should see a movie and and when
toby and andrew come in that audience
reaction was like nothing i've
experienced in a long time and
especially now in the age of covid it
was so
it's so great this movie seems so needed
to restore our faith and movies and the
movie going experience toby and andrew i
have to ask you though how did you get
involved i mean when they came to you i
can't imagine toby they said oh
we want you to do spider-man again
what was it
um
yeah i i
went and had a meeting with um
amy and uh kevin amy pascal and kevin
feige
and and had talked about they sort of
just you know
teased i think amy was like we'd love to
talk to you and you you know what this
is about
and i was like okay
and with sure you're like no i don't
yeah i know i know
maybe you could just give me a little
bit of information but i don't know i
was i gotta say i was intrigued
immediately like
in in that conversation
the intention the kind of love and
celebration
of these movies and what it meant i
think to amy and kevin
was was apparent and to me when artists
or you know people who are
um
steering the creative process
have a kind of authentic genuine
intent of celebration and love it it
just was so apparent in both of them
that
i don't know i just wanted to join that
and um i'm a big fan of tom and those
movies and andrew so
it was definitely intriguing but but yes
i was also going well what are we going
to do
and that was a bit mysterious i did
appreciate
what was shared but it was really about
getting together with these people and
revisiting
you know what
what was part of my history and and
getting a chance to like come together
and
um there there are personal things too
which are
um
kind of resolutions or
a way to revisit and and
um i'm not quite sure how to put it it's
just just to get to get back into that
and
i don't want to say like close the
chapter but revisit and have certain
resolutions
um and and just join in this like loving
creative spirit i wonder what andrew's
going to have to say yeah it's amazing
what about for you andrew i thought well
with tick tick boom and with the eyes of
tammy faye uh we've seen a lot of andrew
garfield in fantastic performances this
year alone when i saw this movie i
wasn't expecting a third one that on
that and amazing uh to see you back in
in these uh in this costume and and this
franchise
so for you what was what was it like
going back well i was just waiting to
see if toby was gonna do it and if toby
was gonna do it
and i i was like well i have no choice
you know
i follow toby to the ends to the ends of
the earth i'm a lemming for toby um no i
but that was a sincerely a big part of
it you know when it when i was
approached about it and
and again it's in a similar way to what
toby was saying it was like oh the
intention feels very pure here it
actually feels
like a great creative idea and a great
creative story it wasn't like they were
just asking us to come and say hi and
then leave again but actually
have us have our presence being in
service to tom
you know being in service to to tom's
journey and and where where he is as
peter parker and how i love the destiny
feeling
of um the multiverse expanding in this
film and actually that without toby's
peter and andrews peter
being present for tom's peter at this
very moment he may not become the peter
parker that he's supposed to become
i love that there's and and and that
maybe he'll he would have lost his
girlfriend and that maybe he would have
gone down a darker path if if toby
hadn't have given hadn't have given um
him that that kind of mentorship moment
that better angel kind of moment so it
was those things i get chills thinking
about it even now um so so for me it was
like and it's the same kind of um
judgment call with any script or any
film it's like is this a story worth
telling and do i want to work with these
people and it was a big double kind of
capitalized yes and then it exceeded my
expectations because the way that tom
and
zendaya and jacob are as a trio
is just like
a kind of magical heaven kind of
friendship
and then so welcoming of me and toby
into the into the gang and then the way
that tom works with john watts and kevin
and amy it's like it's very open it's
very free
and uh so so toby and i
felt not only welcomed but actually
given lots of permission to
to play and to to kind of find find our
way into being of service to tom's tom's
story in this way it was just a kind of
joyful
few weeks that we all got to spend
together which far ex i i you know it
could have been an absolute not like you
kind of think well
getting three spider-men together
couldn't could go one of two ways
and uh i think it's a testament to the
to these guys that it went it went the
way that it went which was a brotherhood
which is just beautiful
i have to say uh toby i just read this
morning sam raimi
just praising this
reunion of all three of you
you know putting you all on the screen
together and what it was in this film i
mean he loved it which is high praise
coming from
high praise
do you have any kind of rehearsal time
to get used to this idea or did you just
jump in and uh you're all in your uh
spider-man uh
mojo yeah
praise the movie yeah it was uh it was
daunting it was very daunting because we
were a long way into shooting before you
guys showed up you know we were maybe
three months into principal photography
and you know the the date of
the other spidermans are coming was
etched on my calendar and i was getting
closer and closer and closer and you
know the closer and closer i got the
more and more nervous i was and then as
soon as i met you guys in atlanta
i realized i had nothing to be nervous
about
but on our first
at our first rehearsal i had asked jacob
and zendaya to come with me
to just kind of be there as like
my support system like i'm gonna go meet
these guys i'm really nervous about it
you have to read the scene and i don't
know how this is going to go because
we're all playing the same character and
we all have to bring our own kind of
heart and soul into this and you know it
means a lot to them and it means a lot
to me does it mean the same
so jacob and they were there on that
first day but i think it was really
strange and almost a little unfair how
they had us put the suits on and then
just jump around in front of a camera
together
like that was one of the most bizarre
experiences of my life and again jacob
and zade were there for that to support
me
but it was an amazing experience and
from day one it was a roller coaster
that i didn't want to get off
uh
and it was a lot of fun and like you
said andrew like it was so collaborative
it was so playful you know from you
cracking toby's back to you coming up
with the idea of pointing out us like it
was all stuff that we came up with on
the day um and it was just a lot of fun
to be able to play with three guys in
spider-man suits it was a strange
experience but one that i won't ever
forget wait what yeah you know and how
did you guys keep this a secret so well
i i know there's all that pressure on
you but i mean it really was a well-kept
secret and that's a hard thing to do in
the age of social media and the internet
and
speculation and did they threaten you
with anything here or what
the worst of it though andrew you
because you were impressed for months
yeah like right there man i'm like out
there and everyone's like why is that
laughing on a press tour just denying
spider-man like
the other two films i'm like dudes like
like look at this stuff so yeah no i
definitely think i
like his time you had the worst part of
it yeah rust into the world just like
coincided with uh having to lie having
to lie for the sake of that audience
reaction i think so and i know
it's i equate it to like you know when
you're organizing a surprise birthday
party
for someone that you love and they keep
telling they keep saying mate just tell
me i hate surprises you know i hate
surprises but deep down you know they
will love the surprise
i justified my ethical kind of
like
unethical lying behavior i call it
fibbing more than lying
right it was quite i kind of enjoyed it
it was quite fun and it kind of
felt like a game of that game werewolf
or mafia where you you know you're the
werewolf and you have to convince
everyone that you're not so i kind of
like turned it into a little bit of a
game for myself
i don't know and it did result in this
kind of like even though there are all
these leaks and all this stuff happening
i think like
there was enough doubt in everyone's
mind going oh god what if it isn't what
if it isn't what if they don't show up
and then so when we did it kind of gave
them that little extra little bit of
icing on top of an already
incredibly deep i watched the movie with
toby for the first time and i was in
pieces like this is a deep movie this
isn't just
fan service which you know it partially
is but like this is a movie that is
about a coming of age like acceptance of
loss acceptance of death
taking responsibility for your gifts and
the
like i was torn open by the journey that
tom went on and that he was having to
that's right it was just like what if it
isn't
having to split with with his girlfriend
his best friend and sacrificed that in
order it's just it's the it's classic
peter parker but it felt totally fresh
and totally reimagined like
his origin like tom's origin story was
happening in his third movie rather than
his first like there's something so
profound so the film i feel stands alone
without me and me and toby showing up i
hope we enhance it but like i think john
and tom have made just something
actually that is exceptionally
moving especially for young people you
know i think it's i think it's a
beautiful film
yeah yeah tom it is highly emotional you
have some
those close-ups of you you know with uh
aunt may and then beyond and the whole
dakota you know if you haven't seen the
movie hold your ears because that ending
is really touching it and and it's
unlike what we've seen before in in the
spider-man universe so to play that must
have been emotional too i would think
yeah i mean it was emotional uh
there definitely was a sense for me as
an actor that this was the last time
that i could potentially don the suit so
a lot of that emotion came from the act
of saying goodbye which is one of the
biggest themes throughout this film so
you know thankfully i was really able to
draw on my own experience and my own
feelings in those moments um
but this film also felt like a huge
celebration you know this movie really
is a celebration of three generations of
cinema uh so at times we would be
getting into these scenes that were
incredibly emotional that you know
they're very taxing
and i was so happy
to be there that i had to go at it a
different way and kind of go wow look at
my life look what's happened to me i'm
working with toby mcguire and andrew
garfield and we're telling this story
and i would get emotional
at kind of how proud i was of the
situation that we were in and that what
we were doing and that i really believed
in what we were doing um so yeah it was
tough but you know anything
hard is is worthwhile um and you know i
was happy to kind of really push myself
and to make this film you know more
emotional than superhero films have been
in the past uh but uh but yeah so a lot
of it was i was drawing on my own kind
of feelings as we went along yeah toby
this feels like a culmination in fact i
i did a little interview with amy pascal
and she described it that way she said
this movie
is a culmination of 20 years what began
with you and your three and now going
full circle here uh is that the way you
look at it too when you looked at this
that this is like
the end of one thing maybe the beginning
of another somehow but but the end here
of what you started
well i'll say i remember being on set
and it was i believe our last day
andrew and
it was uh
it was really amazing and i had i had
the awareness of this you know the the
20 years of history but
looking at
um
amy and kevin and realizing that they've
been there through all the different
iterations
and it was really powerful just
personally it was really powerful it was
powerful for me to be
working with andrew and tom and powerful
in a in a legitimately moving emotional
way
and then
to witness
amy and kevin and consider their
journeys through all the films it was
it was really impactful um
and and yeah i was i was
just grateful every day i really it was
such a rich experience and as
the guys have touched on the kind of um
sharing of something and the the
brotherhood of it it was it was just so
rich emotional
and i i don't know i i'm not like
sitting there conceptually thinking
about that all the time but i would have
moments where that kind of stuff would
hit me you know day to day it was
it was
just a beautiful kind of unfolding of
this story and these relationships
so i was more just like in
in that uh on the day-to-day but i'd
have these like reflection moments which
were
quite powerful and and elegantly
woven ultimately because it's actually
you're thinking about taking 20 years of
history
and revisiting that and how do you
how do you balance um
all of these things in each each of our
kind of series of films have
you know they're the characters are
we're playing the same character but
they're all so unique and and the
the way those films and characters
evolved in those films are unique and
then to bring all of that together
including
um
uh
you know all of our super villains and
and all of that it's it was pretty wild
to witness the
immensity of all of this history coming
together and being put into
what andrew is saying is this
you know
stand-alone worthwhile story
um and and i too just wanted to say with
with the coda
of the movie i was really
touched emotionally but also i just
thought it had such a sweet elegance to
it like that
was so amazing and i i agree in terms of
the origin story and the kind of coming
of age or or
you know
tom your character stepping into this
different kind of maturity and
responsibility
and all done with this like really sweet
sad elegant touch it was it was just
beautiful yeah it's um it's it's a
remarkable movie the way they did this i
got a big shout out here to john watts
who i had seen cop car and i think the
first time i talked to you tom it was
with john and when you had done the
first spider-man and all all i could do
to do is talk about this little movie
cop car that he did and think wow this
guy's going somewhere what was it like
working with john on this film for you
guys andrew and and uh uh toby had not
before obviously tom had what was that
experience like
it's so funny because what toby just
said about the kind of
in those moments of awareness where you
realize you were that we were
bringing in
20 years of history and then some into a
frame every day
that hugeness that we that i know that
we only
got a sense of in moments and i remember
maybe the first time i got a sense of it
where where i think we were on a
scaffolding and like we were talking to
dr strange who wasn't actually there and
tom turned to us and said that something
doesn't feel quite right about this it
feels a bit awkward or like we just kind
of stood here and and both me and toby
were like yeah this feels a little weird
we feel a little odd and then in that
moment john watts comes up the um
the scaffolding goes
that's the movie that's it we got it
it's the
part of the film this is this is the
moment and we're all like oh
we're insane then
we weren't seeing what he was seeing
which he then just showed us and it was
just the three of us in our suits in the
same frame
and just how
profoundly moving that is
unto itself the scaffolding for
spider-man fans the world over and i
think it was at that point where i was
like oh no this is gonna people are
gonna like this movie a lot
you know like or this this element of
things but in regards to the bigness
that toby was talking about
it also
mostly just felt very small like we were
making cop car like we were
just doing an independent spider-man
film and that's why the tone of these
films that tom and john have created
together feel
like
michael j fox john hughes indie kind of
um
small details awkward
beautiful humor proper deep intimate
love
stuff with huge scope but like at the
essence of it is just pure heart and
and that's what it felt like with john
it felt like there was i was just so
overwhelmed by
how unperturbed he was by what he was
trying to achieve like it was so big
objectively but
his his calmness his
ability to allow actors to improvise to
play and then for him to throw out wild
ideas in the mix to let takes run and
run and run to to give us time to really
find what we were doing and to go down
the wrong path to then find towards the
new path the right path
i was just incredibly impressed and
actually just really grateful for the
experience with with john he he's
someone that
he's a real actors director and and that
is especially
hard to feel in the midst of the
machinery
of um a film that does have this scope
and i i know that tom will
will be able to talk to that even even
better than me
yeah tom that that's quite a
collaboration you've had the last three
films with him and he's done an a really
interesting job with this
yeah it's interesting i mean john and i
spoke yesterday for the first time since
the film has been released
and i think it took us so long because
we needed time to just kind of let the
dust settle experience and then we spoke
yesterday and and the first kind of ten
minutes of our conversation was kind of
like we we're both kind of in disbelief
of what's happened and what we've
achieved you know i'm talking to him
like i remember meeting you for the
first time in my trailer i was 18 years
old
and you were you had never directed a
movie like this before and both of us
hadn't a [ __ ] clue what we were doing
we were both like i i was petrified he
was petrified and then on this movie we
were able to put our best foot forward
go on that go there day one and feel
confident in our capabilities um
and it's just been one of those
relationships that i've had that i will
cherish forever you know john and i have
no boundaries with each other you know
we have no fear in telling each other
how it is and being honest and i think
when you make these kind of movies it's
very important to make sure that you
don't lose the heart and soul of why you
started doing this in the first place
and i think john watts was the perfect
person to kind of keep that throughout
the trilogy
but for me as an actor he's kind of
he's like a gold mine he will let you do
whatever you want until you've gone too
far then he'll reel you back in and
he'll always set you on the right track
and he's someone that you can really
trust
he's incredibly creative you know he
never sacrifices quality for quantity
you know like he is the kind of person
that will shut a scene down and say
we're done for the day we're going to
pick this up tomorrow because it's not
reaching my expectations and that's
happened a few times on this film and in
the previous two films so i've always
really appreciated his his bravery to
say to the studio
i'm finished for the day i'm not
shooting this scene until we come up
with something better
i think that's an incredible quality and
something i know i couldn't have done it
i would have been like yeah just we'll
do four hours over until we figure it
out don't tell me what to do so yeah so
i've always been a huge fan of john's
and he's a great friend and i'm so glad
that you guys had just as an amazing
experience with him as i have
i have to ask you toby i'm sure people
are wondering so what was it like these
costumes
uh the costume designs it's you know
iconic what was it like getting back
into that suit
um well you know what once you get
through the process of like you know
really peeling it onto your body
it was
i don't know a lot of things it was
uncomfortable getting it on and then and
then it's a goof and then it also has a
sort of
um
you know
i guess
a sort of a power in a sense because it
brings me back into that character it
really does
um
there's so much affinity for this
character it means so much to so many
people
that you know once the sort of goofiness
of being in
uh lycra or spandex you know once that
goes away you're like oh wow this is
this is cool this is that
sort of um
a responsibility but a but a blessing
like something that i get to do that i'm
grateful for
and
so that was fun but but honestly like
being with these guys it really was um
[Music]
just a much much richer experience than
i anticipated or
that i could really even express in
words i i just
i know that's not the question about the
suit but
but the suit is it just
to get to be there with these guys in
their suits and
whether it was like dancing around or
playing around in scenes and improving
or
um
you know
feeling that kind of sense of service to
each other
um and the character being in service to
humanity
it really
gives a certain perspective and then
and then the the kind of trust and
openness that i had with these guys and
uh john and amy and everyone it it just
brought this
really
open
i don't know i just felt super
safe and like we were all on the same
team and all in support of each other
and it just brought out this
this
yeah i don't know how to put it other
than just like this really loving
uh fun creative experience that
um
that i was just like sitting in
gratitude every day uh which is not
always the case when you're working on
something you know even just from the
standpoint of like
trying to figure out what you're doing
and and it all it wasn't without its
challenges
but it it all just unfolded the way it
needed to or
whatever just it had a sense of this
kind of destiny to it as well so i guess
the suit was the the doorway to that
it's it's i have to mention the
theatrical experience here which has
been threatened and
and people say oh it's the beginning of
the end and everybody's going to sit on
their couch and watch movies at home and
things and this movie is almost
single-handedly being credited for
proving that that is not true that that
movies exist in movie theaters at the
way they were designed by their
filmmakers to be seen and this is the
perfect example of a movie
that if if you can in any way see it
with an audience the collective
experience of watching this movie is
again it's like unlike
anything i've seen in a long time that
that kind of feeling you get and uh and
it's got to be preserved and so all
three of you are here part of the reason
why
movies are going to go on to give me
hope
you know for this tom tom uh you in
particular you might go on and do
more spider-man i'm going to try to get
a scoop here uh
what's gonna happen uh
i
the truth is that the truthful answer
and i've done a whole press tool where
all i do is lie
and you're not gonna like the truth i
don't know the answer to that question
yeah
i don't know the answer to that question
this film for me
was as special as an experience could
ever be
sharing the screen with these guys you
know playing spider-man can be quite an
alienating experience because you know
we're you know the three blokes and
we're the only three blokes who have
done it so to share that with you two
and for it to have been such a wonderful
experience of which i have such amazing
memories
i don't know there's part of me that
feels like it's the perfect time to to
to jump off the building and swing off
into the sunset and net and let the next
lucky young kid come in uh to don the
suit i know i love this character and i
know that i am not ready to say goodbye
but if it is time for me to say goodbye
then i will do so proudly knowing that i
have achieved everything i wanted to
with this character uh and sharing it
with these boys will be forever one of
the most special experiences of my
career so if it's time it's time if it's
not it's not
but at the at the moment i don't know
well we certainly uh can't wait to see
what you do next and uh all three of you
and again congratulations uh andrew on
all your other films this year which are
great and i'm happy to say i've seen all
of them in a theater uh and uh they're
all different and all of you are big
champions of independent filmmaking too
so i loved what you said about this felt
like
uh an independent film in its own way
even on the scale that it was being
produced and and you're all big
champions
of that uh uh throughout your career so
um keep it going and thanks for joining
us here and talking this rare
opportunity to see three spiderman
together this is so exciting thanks guys
very rare thank you
thank you
all right well
okay to address tom holland's statement
at the end this may have been
recorded before kevin feige came out and
said yes we are doing more spider-man
with tom holland because we already know
that this is an unlisted video i will
link the video in the description down
below and in the comments i'll pin it
it's an unlisted video on the official
spider-man youtube channel this was uh
this was so cool just to see the three
of them
just as people talking together i'm
still waiting for the day where we're
gonna get to see the three of them
in person interacting with each other i
i want to see behind the scenes photos
or videos of all of them together that's
what i want to see i want to see them
goofing off and cracking jokes because
we we've heard about it we've heard
about how how much fun they had they
mentioned it on here like there's a lot
of love that went into this movie there
was a lot of love that went to this
movie and you know
you could see it in the movie you know
you can really see it in the movie it
was done right i like what they talked
about were like
like it kind of is fan service but it's
not it had meaning
and uh you know
it's kind of funny that andrew was like
if toby does it i'm do what i meant and
toby you know
he he thought about it and it meant
something to him and it meant something
to andrew and tom which i think made for
just a great great movie this is a 30
minute video already so i'm going to
quit talking but i i love this i i can't
wait to see more of this but let me know
what you all thought about it let me
know in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video don't forget to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
spiderman news like this and marvel news
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter for live updates
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof